[Musique]
alors cette semaine je veux vous ramener
en 2019 dans une histoire que vous avez
peut-être probablement déjà entendu
parce qu'elle est quand même été
beaucoup mieux médiatisé c'est
l'histoire d'un grand-père et de sa
petite fille de 12 ans à l'époque qui
sont allés à une banque dans la ville
devant couvert pour ouvrir un compte et
les employés de la banque le trouvant
les trouvant tous les deux suspects ont
appelé les polices deux agents de police
ont arrêté l'aîné et sa petite fille de
12 ans et les emmenés que vous pouvez
imaginer que ce fut un moment assez
traumatisant pour un enfant qui s'en
venait faire l'ouverture d'un compte
bancaire ce qui devrait être une action
très banale en soit au Canada mais qui
dans le cas de beaucoup de personnes
autochtones que ça soit dans les milieux
de la santé dans les milieux de la
banque dans beaucoup de milieux où on
veut aller chercher des services peuvent
devenir comme dans ce coup-ci un moment
qui change ta vie qui vient de faire
face à du racisme ou la discrimination
dans le système
euh c'est passé depuis 2019 dans les
cours les cours de droits de la personne
et justement ça a été reconnu comme un
acte de racisme systémique c'est-à-dire
que cela est arrivé parce qu'ils étaient
membres des Premières nations parce
qu'ils ont vécu du racisme et la
discrimination il y a une entente qui a
été fait une compensation pour les
victimes il y a eu 100000 dollars qui
étaient donnés justement pour le centre
de réparation de justice réparatrice
excusez-moi de la communauté de la
nation elle turque et en plus il y a eu
promesse d'une cérémonie d'excuses
et justement c'est pour ça que j'arrive
aujourd'hui cette cérémonie a eu lieu
cette semaine cependant elle a dû être
annulé dû à l'absence des deux policiers
qui ont été à la base de l'arrestation
qui a été reconnu comme un acte de
discrimination
et ça le fait en sorte que dans le
système de justice réparatrice de la
nationale on peut pas avoir une
cérémonie d'excuses ou pardon si les
deux personnes qui sont justement à
devoir demander pardon ne sont pas là il
y avait des membres du chemin des
représentants des policiers des
personnes très influentes qui étaient là
mais cependant les deux personnes à la
base ceux qui auraient dû être là pour
demander des excuses officielles ne
l'était pas donc on a des annuler la
cérémonie on a dû remettre très
respectueusement les cadeaux à ceux qui
étaient venus emporter puisqu'il n'était
pas les représentants justement et qui
n'étaient pas ceux qui devaient demander
pardon aux demandes la communauté qui
avait été biaisé là on va rentrer dans
beaucoup de discussions parce que les
personnes qui ont fait leur arrestation
étaient elles-mêmes racisées on va
rentrer dans la discussion que c'était
leur travail ce sont pas des membres
d'une communauté comme les membres de la
nation et sont tous un membre d'une
communauté donc toutes les aspects de la
justice réparatrice qui sont maintenant
amenés de l'avant qui font maintenant
partie du processus légal et des droit
des papes autochtones va commencer à
apparaître de plus en plus justement
dans les décisions légales dans les
décisions de cours et on va voir espèce
de sucre à la corde entre le droit
des personnes autochtones d'avoir des
représentations de leurs droits
ancestraux des droits qui ont jamais été
effacés qui ont toujours été reconnues
d'ailleurs par le droit canadien et
aussi le système celui qui a dû être
infaillé pendant très longtemps pour
pouvoir faire en sorte qu'on se sente
justifier de l'appliquer sur des
personnes autochtones telles que ça a
été faite pour les pensionnats les
réserves etc
vous voyez il y a une lutte qui se fait
les membres de cette situation
communautaire là vont le dire ben je
dirais pas moi je suis pas obligé ils
ont payé ça va être vraiment le droit
individuel qui va être primé alors
qu'ici on va parler vraiment d'une
responsabilité communautaire d'un d'un
rapport à l'ensemble du groupe puis
justement à la cohésion de la société
donc en annulant est-ce qu'on annule
est-ce qu'on est en comment je pourrais
dire en déficit de de la cour qui sait
on va utiliser ok ben une demie
cérémonie c'est assez pour dire qu'il y
a eu une représentation du du milieu
policier ça va être intéressant parce
que ça devient du droit canadien ça
devient une situation légale qui va se
voir de plus en plus surtout dans un
Canada qui est en mode réconciliation et
de plus en plus maintenant les enjeux
dans les cours que ce soit un cours
suprême pour d'appel cours des droits de
la personne justement pour devenir de
plus en plus intéressant ils vont avoir
un impact réel sur le Canada sur la
situation pour les communautés
autochtones et justement sur un respect
un retour justement des structures qui
nous ont fait vivre bien avant l'arrivée
des premiers Européens des premières
structures dites légales puisqu'ils
existaient il y avait un système de
justice qui était là qui a jamais été
facile que jamais été oublié qu'on a
essayé d'enlever du système canadien
mais qui revient parce que justement
elles font partie de l'ADN du Canada
super intéressant on va suivre encore ce
qui va se passer avec ça parce que quand
on parle de de réconciliation on peut
pas parler de réconciliation sans la
réparation et ça c'est un cas très
flagrant de réparation qui est dû et on
espère vraiment qu'il va y avoir un
effort de la part de ces deux agents de
police parce que c'est très peu demandé
c'est la comme on dit c'est la barre la
plus basse de l'échelle que de se dire
je m'excuse alors je souhaite une belle
semaine et j'espère que vous hésitez pas
à partager cette vidéo